[Music]
historic trends and violence can't be
assessed by headlines headlines are
about things that happen and they give
you no indication whatsoever of how
common a particular activity is because
you never see a reporter standing
outside a school saying Here I am in
front of Maplewood high school which
hasn't been shot up today or Here I am
in the capital of Mozambique and there's
no civil war
so forget headlines you have to the only
way to answer the question of what are
the trends and violence is to look at
data where you count the number of
occurrences as a proportion of the
number of opportunities and you see
whether that's changed over time so
since I wrote better angels of our
nature in I sent it off to the press in
end of 2010 so the data that were
available from or from Oh 8 oh nine I
keep yearly updates on what's happened
to those trends and with the exception
of civil war which after a roller
coaster downward from the end of World
War two has shown something of an uptick
because of the Syrian civil war its
wiped out about 13 years of progress
taking us back to the level of about
2,000 but it's still a fraction of the
level that it was at in the 60s 70s and
80s when you had not just eight or nine
civil wars going on at a time but 25 or
30 we tend to forget them we tend to be
amnesia about all those nasty wars in
Africa and Southeast Asia that were
going on in the in the 70s and 80s but a
lot of them had a considerable death
toll so it's clearly things have gotten
worse in in Syria they've gotten worse
in Ukraine and
Pakistan but the global trend has not
reversed the progress that we have seen
by any means then all the other trends
such as homicide which kills far more
people than Wars continues to go down
sexual violence at least in countries
that have good data have continued to go
down rape and domestic violence child
abuse has continued to go down more and
more states and countries have abolished
capital punishment even democratization
government the absence of government
violence where we're aware of
backsliding in countries like Venezuela
and Turkey and Russia but still the
global trend continues to be that the
world is getting more democratic we
don't read about the countries that have
liberalized but we hear about the
countries that increase their repression
and that they do exist but on the whole
the world has become more democratic as
well as less homicidal less gender-based
violence less child abuse and so on and
even in the category of war you can
divide Wars into wars between countries
old-fashioned Wars of country a declares
war on country B and civil wars and the
first category interstate Wars
government on each side has been in
sputtering decline for many decades
there are fewer and fewer wars between
countries the wars that exist are civil
wars and that has that record has
continued to to to improve namely we've
had zero interstate wars since the
better angels of our nature was
published and in fact we've had zero
interstate war since the American
invasion of Iraq in 2003 and
historically wars between countries tend
to kill more people than civil wars so
even with the backsliding that we've
seen in in the case of civil war in the
case of the most destructive form of
wars the world is still not seeing a
return today the bad old days of the 70s
and 80s
[Music]